[Music]
i am so excited today because i am
joined by victoria justice and adam
demos who's starring in perfect pairing
which is out on netflix now we're gonna
be talking spoilers in this interview so
come back after you've seen the film how
you guys doing today good how are you
doing
good i'm really excited to talk to you
guys i absolutely love the film and i
think people are so excited about this
film being out and
victoria i especially love your cover of
the song home here was it always going
to be that song and do you get nerves
doing covers
um so i found out when i was in
quarantine in sydney our producer robin
called me because i was sort of worried
about what song i was going to sing it
wasn't it wasn't um scripted to be that
song and so i was like oh this could
very easily be really cheesy um and when
she told me it was going to be that song
i was
thrilled over the moon because that's
always been one of my favorite songs and
so to be able to sing it was so exciting
to me
and um
to do a cover like that no i i don't
think i mean i'm always a little nervous
but
i think it was fun and it's not like
this isn't like a big musical
performance it's like a very casual
um sort of natural real moment unfolding
and it's really like more about the
connection between our two characters
and so it was uh but it's one of my
favorite scenes it was really fun to
film
yeah i love that scene and it does come
off supernatural too so props to you
guys for just crushing that now thank
you
adam what was your favorite thing about
having victoria as your scene partner
that scene we just got to basically be a
little mini concert for free and also
not even for free we're technically
getting paid to be there
to listen to us
no well it's so incredibly you know what
i mean so it's like we got to sit around
an actual fire
um chilling out while she sings a song
it's like
there you go
yeah you got you got front row seats so
you get all these great things yeah
now
victoria with you i the question that's
gotta be on everyone's mind is are you a
white or red wine person or both and
like do you have like a wine regimen or
seasons you drink it in kind of thing um
i'm definitely a red wine person i love
a good cab sav is my favorite um
but yeah other than that like i'm not
i'm not like a huge wine drinker like
but
i don't know i think he's more of a
i don't know with the seasons and the
climate i mean i'll have it all that's
uh yeah like i think i'd just i'm open
to more you love caps i love cabs have
too but i'm not mad at whatever you
don't discriminate
adam there's a scene in the movie when
your character picks up a tree snake was
that really you and was that a real tree
snake that you were yeah that was that
was me and that was a real tree snake
yeah yeah we luckily had the um
professional off to off camera and so i
was like as soon as i'd walk off he'd
take it but yeah it was f it was full on
and then you know more takes it went on
and
it didn't appreciate
yeah it was kind of a one-take
snake and it was like after a few we
started to get a little bit upset but it
was cool experience
yeah
it looks great i was like man
this guy can do everything uh
now victoria is there a type of
genre or type of film
um
series that you would love to do you
haven't explored yet in your careers or
something that you kind of i that you
want to do
um
i mean i'd love to do like a good
psychological thriller i think would be
really cool
but
i mean at the end of the day like i
i don't know i i really do love making
movies like this i love a good romantic
comedy and i love musicals that's
something that i'm i'm very much
passionate about and would love to do
next but really yeah like to keep
working
whatever
yeah i think we want to see more of that
especially i loved when you did rocky
horror so that'd be cool to see you do
more thank you
um adam you're on the verge of joining
the netflix hall of fame having multiple
projects on this prolific service has
how has that changed your life anyway
like you getting noticed more of where
you go is it kind of like surreal in a
sense i mean it yeah
yeah you get noticed more i guess but
it's um i mean i love these guys so much
they've they they've shown a lot of
faith in me and i just
just want to work my butt off for him
you know it's um it's i was saying
before it's like you can work on
something you're really proud of but you
don't know if it's going to get to the
masses or what it but you know with
these guys it's like you know the time
it comes out here i know my mom can
watch perfect pair in australia at the
same time if she wants to wake up that
early
so um yeah they've shown a lot of faith
in me and so yeah i'm i'm just i'm so
grateful really i mean it's not like
that many people watch netflix though i
mean it's like 222 million or something
it's like
exactly
well everybody who watches netflix if
you're out there watch victoria adam
crush it in a perfect pairing it's on
netflix now thank you so much for
joining me guys and we'll talk to you in
the future thank you so much have a good
day have a good one bye guys